CBS News has confirmed president Trump's
son-in-law and senior White House
advisor Jared Kushner is under scrutiny
in the FBI Russia investigation
the issue is Kushner's meetings during
the presidential transition with
Russia's US ambassador and a Moscow
banker with ties to Russian security
investigators are seeking evidence of
Russian meddling in the 2016 election
and possible collusion with the Trump
campaign Jeff Piquet's is outside FBI
headquarters in Washington
Jeff good morning good morning Jared
Kushner is now under an FBI microscope
he was a key figure during the campaign
and during the transition to the White
House investigators are scrutinizing his
actions and interactions with Russian
officials and whether they included
something improper after traveling with
the president for most of his overseas
trip mr. Trump's son-in-law Jared
Kushner returned to the u.s. amid new
revelations about the scope of the
Russia investigation CBS News has
confirmed that part of the investigation
includes scrutinizing Kushner's contacts
with Russian officials Kushner is
acknowledged meeting with Russian
ambassador Sergei kis lyac in December
kis lyac then arranged for Kushner to
meet with the head of Russian own VEB
Bank
sergej Gourcuff who was trained by
Russia's Federal Security Service or FSB
investigators are looking into the
nature of the contacts as part of its
ongoing FBI counterintelligence
investigation Kushner's attorney
released a statement saying mr. Kushner
previously volunteered to share with
Congress what he knows about these
meetings he will do the same if he is
contacted in connection with any other
inquiry Kushner is offered to meet with
the Senate Intelligence Committee which
is also conducting a separate
investigation there was no collusion
since he took office the president has
dismissed the Russia investigation as a
scam and a witch-hunt the entire thing
has been a witch-hunt and there is no
collusion between certainly myself and
my campaign but the FBI investigation
continues to expand to include people
close to him and connected to his case
pain also among those under FBI scrutiny
former campaign chairman Paul Manafort
former national security adviser Michael
Flynn a campaign foreign policy adviser
Carter page and president Trump's
longtime friend Roger stone there has
been a flurry of new developments
related to the Russia investigation in
recent days a White House official
acknowledged that and said that everyone
gets their moment in the hot seat and
circus Nora
alright Jeff thank you